hey guys ran right over here dance I've
heard over here we're gonna check out
the trailer today for Deus Ex mankind
divided I will be yeah everyone's
freaking out about this trailer
damn dude each and every this must not
go wrong this you trust Mustang
bye
I don't know it's not like a city boy
okay
sometimes you just have to let go and
embrace what you've become
it worked for the shadows for years in
future manipulating lives
control information innocence a guy
ooh Elmo
in the wild aurochs
we will stop but not
why
innocence
out of difficult to learn
these should be your might as well
brother
the promise of a golden Aichi sofa
I won't let it happen again
like their wings in this trailer some
badass [ __ ] right there so we got a guy
who's um oh it talks like this cuz
that's how every hero should sound in
movies and videogames now so I'm not too
familiar with this franchise but I've
only heard amazing things about it the
first game was one of the few games from
back in the day that lets you really
affect the outcome of the ending but
basically you were once human and then
you had a lot of replacements I don't
quite remember why I kind of get a
looper and escape from New York vibe
from it
a looper bleed wanna play run or not
looper I don't know why I said loop a
man as a trailer speaking from a purely
trailer aspect that looked [ __ ]
amazing
I will admit I forgot I was watching a
video game trailer yeah yeah I was
really pulled into it like if this was
an animated movie I would totally check
it out yeah it looks really cool the
violence looks awesome the powers that
you get as the main character look
pretty [ __ ] sweet he has like the
invisibility he has the whatever that
turning into metal block advice thing he
has going on well here's the thing is
that if it looks this good right now
it's like on a cinematic aspect I think
it's gonna look pretty goddamn good when
it comes to gameplay I feel like now
we're starting to figure out graphically
what the new consoles are capable of
doing and PCs always just been PC so I
think this game the one thing cinematic
trailer is like recently they used to
get me a lot more pumped but video games
when when they come out sometimes they
don't live up to that what the cinematic
trailers Gaeta evil went in for example
was like a big [ __ ] deal it has
awesome cinematic effects even the
gameplay looks pretty cool and then you
play it and you're like this isn't as
interesting is it dude it looks like a
[ __ ] piss 2 games but I like stories
that deal with conspiracy you know like
I can get
for like a Da Vinci Code or angels and
demons lumen a Deus yes thank you I was
watching this associate lumen are
Illuminati
yeah terrorists he looks cool I mean he
calls him brother so they must be
brothers oh you don't know that it could
be like it could be like brothers or it
could be like brother I think it'd be
more interesting if they were actually
brothers I think it would be more
interesting and there's probably some
little thing there's probably someone
that's played the game that can answer
that question in the comments down below
for us anyway guys thanks for telling us
that trailer is out if you're new to the
channel you know you can do you can
subscribe to the real rejects dan has a
gaming channel plays games on there
jerks off beforehand makes them a really
comfortable gamer and check it out you
can follow us on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter where I jerk off before every
tweet so I tweet three times a day
Daniel Sanchez I he said love your
channel it's always kick-ass man you
guys [ __ ] Rock thanks well you know
honestly it can't always be kick-ass
there are gonna be days where I'm not
feeling so good today I'm feeling a
little bit down and physically don't
feel the greatest which is weird because
I worked out today so I should be
producing a lot of positive hormones but
it doesn't seem to be doing it for me
right now see Daniel sometimes you just
got to be honest about what's going on
here right and right now
tacos it's tacos and I'm depressed
without tacos see an improv they teach
you to say yes and so in tacos and tacos
this is so much yes and there's just
agreed that tacos are good tacos yes
tacos